[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELLIOTT BROSSARD: So first,
a bit about who we are,
who your presenters are here.
So my name is Elliot.
I'm an engineer on
the BigQuery team.
I'm also a tech
lead and manager.
My specialty is SQL.
So I'm not the star of this
show, though, honestly.
I'm joined here by Subra,
from The Home Depot.
And if you're going to
listen to any of it,
listen to what he's
saying, because he's
going to talk about data
management at Home Depot.
And you'll get a lot
of real-life experience
about what Home
Depot actually does.
So thank you all for coming,
and I hope it's a good session.
So the first thing
I want to talk about
is this topic of big metadata.
Everybody throws around
the term big data,
which is cool in itself--
BigQuery excels at processing
huge volumes of data.
But the thing that I
want to talk about here
is actually the data
around that data,
or as I like to call it,
big metadata, in this case.
So for a bit of an overview,
BigQuery's architecture
looks something like this.
There's a lot of
pieces I omitted,
but you can generally
think of the system
as being roughly this shape.
So we have things here
like, you can get data
in through streaming ingestion.
There's bulk loading.
We have this data
transfer service
where you can get data in that
I didn't even picture here.
We have interfaces like the UI.
We have client
libraries, et cetera.
Some of the cool pieces
behind the scenes
are things like our high
available compute cluster.
This is where we
actually run the queries
that you give to us.
We have our storage system.
And then what ties this all
together is this really fast
network that Google built.
It's hard to imagine
building this
system anywhere else
just because we have such
a great infrastructure that
makes this possible.
So the thing that I
want to focus on today
is the data that
we actually manage
behind the scenes for you
and what goes into that.
So I want to start by talking
about what makes a table.
So we've got a variety
of attributes of a table.
So there's things like
the table ID itself.
This is like the name
of it, so to speak.
We have this schema
of the table,
various attributes like
whether it's partitioned,
what partition in column there
is, whether it's clustered,
that sort of thing.
We have the amount of data
that is being stored--
so the number of bytes,
the number of rows,
that kind of thing.
We have the description
of the table.
You can edit this
yourself, for example.
And then we have the
actual data itself.
So that's great, but what
really makes a table?
What is the actual
representation
behind the scenes of
tables in BigQuery?
So we use this format
that we call capacitor.
There's a great blog post
about this, actually.
I don't have enough time to
go into the details of this,
but capacitor is
a format that lets
us really efficiently represent
nested and repeated data.
And this is what
we use in BigQuery.
We developed this
format ourself.
This is sort of a
secret sauce, so
to speak, of BigQuery that
makes queries really fast.
So we store this data
for you in this format.
And when we store these
capacitor files, all of these
are encrypted at rest.
They're durable, meaning that
if one copy of a file on a disk
ends up getting
deleted or there's
a problem with the hardware
and that kind of thing,
we're not going to lose it.
It's also highly available.
So if part of a data
center is not operational,
we're able to still
serve you that data.
And there's no chance of
it being lost, essentially.
So the thing that
we do is that we
have this concept that
builds on these files called
storage sets.
So storage sets are a grouping
of these capacitor files.
And a storage set is a
combination of a few things.
So it's a path to the files
in our distributed storage.
It has a partition key
for partition tables.
It has a timestamp
of when we actually
committed this data, when
we wrote it to our metadata.
It has a UUID--
so some unique identifier
for that storage set.
And then it has a
variety of stats.
So this includes things like
column sizes, for example.
So when you run a
query against a table,
we fetch these column
sizes from these storage
sets to figure out how
much data will actually be
scanned as part of that query.
Then it has a state.
So it can be in a pending state.
It can be committed.
Or it can be in a garbage state,
meaning that it was deleted
or is no longer applicable.
So to give you a sense
of scale of this,
we have on the order of billions
of storage sets in BigQuery.
I just ran a query last night.
This is a current
snapshot of the system.
So this tends to
change over time.
But currently, it's on
the order of billions.
So that's a lot of metadata.
So why do we do this?
Why do we have these
storage sets in BigQuery?
Well, the reason that we do this
is, it's the unit of atomicity.
And what I mean by that
is that it gives us
properties like this.
So when I select from a table
at a particular timestamp, what
it means is that I
ignore any stored
sets that are in a pending
or a garbage state.
I only read the ones that were
committed as of that timestamp
at which I'm reading the data.
If they weren't
committed at that point,
if they were committed
later, then I ignore them.
So when they perform operations
like loading data or DML
queries, all that sort of thing,
all these operations either
succeed or they don't.
And when you run
a query, you never
see partially-written data.
So the property that we provide
is known as snapshot isolation.
Basically, you never
have to worry that when
you run a query that you'll see
the partial state of the table.
Because we have this unit
of atomicity called storage
sets, when we persist
that data, either you're
seeing all of it or none.
So what creates storage sets?
So when you load
it into the system,
we create a storage
set per partition,
or when you stream
data in, what we do
is we actually buffer that
data that you're sending us
and then periodically flush this
data into our managed storage.
When you run a create
table select statement,
we're actually taking
the results of that query
and writing it to storage
sets behind the scenes.
Or when you run DML statements--
update, insert, et cetera, we're
creating storage sets, as well,
as part of those operations.
So let's look at how
this works in practice.
Imagine I had this query where
I'm selecting from a table.
So I'm selecting these
couple of columns, x and y,
from this table here.
So what do we do?
First, what we do is,
we list the storage
sets in our Spanner metadata.
We use Spanner.
Spanner is awesome.
This is how we keep track
of all of our metadata
behind the scenes.
So we list the storage
sets for these tables
from our Spanner metadata.
And then we send a request
to our query engine
that describes the mapping of
these tables to these storage
sets that we're going to
read as part of the query.
As a brief architecture, there's
a lot of pieces missing here,
but you can roughly
think of it like this.
So as a client,
you send a request
with a query to BigQuery.
There's a couple of steps here.
We have this router
behind the scenes that
figures out where
to actually send
the query when we receive it.
It goes to this job server.
We have these Spanner
tables for job metadata,
table metadata, et cetera.
And what we're doing is,
we're looking up data
for the tables
that you reference.
And then we use that as part of
execution in our query engine
itself.
And you can see down here, so
we have our distributed storage
system with capacitor files
that are actually on disk.
And when we go to read a
table, what we're doing is,
we're reading the
capacitor files
relevant to that
particular table that's
being referenced here.
So how does this work for
partition tables, though?
So for partition
tables, we actually
have one or more storage
sets for each day
for which you have data.
So in this example, I
have data for the 7th,
the 8th, the 10th, and so on.
And so I can have one
or more storage sets
for each of those days.
Storage sets can
span partitions.
So what happens when
I run a query is
that when I select
from a partition table,
I match any of these storage
sets for the days that
are referenced.
So in this example, I'm
selecting data for the 10th.
So what I do is
that, as BigQuery,
when I'm fetching
the storage that's
relevant to the query at hand,
I filter out the ones outside
of the 10th here.
So because I had
this filter where
I restricted the data I
was reading to the 10th,
it means I could ignore any
storage sets outside of that.
So you may be familiar
with the concept
of clustering in BigQuery.
What clustering lets you
do is actually lay out
the data in your tables
according to some clustering
keys.
And when you do
this, what happens
is that we're
actually laying out
the files based on
the clustering keys
that you provided us.
So these storage set files are
sorted by the cluster keys,
essentially.
So what happens in this case?
So when you select
from a table that's
both partitioned and
clustered and you
have a query that
looks like this--
so I'm restricting the data that
I'm reading to the 10th, here.
And then I'm restricting
further that the price is
between these two
different values.
So if my table was clustered
by price, what I would do
is that first, I
would apply that date
filter that you gave me.
So I would restrict the
data being read to the 10th.
And then further,
what I can do is,
because you gave me this
filter on this price column,
I can filter out more of
the data behind the scenes.
And then this is
passed along in terms
of reduced query time,
and also a lower query
cost for the query itself.
So that was on
selecting from a table.
But what happens when I
actually update a table?
So when I go and update a
partition table, what we do is,
we list the storage
sets that match whatever
filter you gave us, if any.
So in this case, I have this
filter on the 8th or the 10th.
And then what I do
is, I run a query
and I actually rewrite
the effective storage sets
for this query.
So what this looks like
is that, in this case,
I've restricted the
data being modified
to these particular
storage sets here
based on that filter
that you gave me.
And then what I
end up doing is, I
decide that, based on
running this query,
I end up modifying
these storage sets.
And then I replace
these, essentially,
and mark the old ones as being
in, now, a garbage state.
And now I have this
new data that I've
committed for this table.
And again, all this is atomic.
So if somebody else is running
a query at the same time,
they're not going to see
the partially-modified state
of the storage while
it's in transit.
So we also allow simultaneous
updates on petition tables.
I can actually have
two updates running
at the same time that
modify different dates
within this table.
So in this example,
I have a query
that's modifying both
the 9th and 10th here--
or, sorry, the 8th and the 10th.
And then I have another one
that's modifying the 7th.
And these are OK as
long as they don't
have conflicts between them.
So I have one query
that goes and rewrites
the storage sets for
the 8th and the 10th,
and then one that's
modifying the 7th.
And there's no conflict,
because the queries
are reading and
modifying storage
sets in different
partitions as part of this.
So we also provide this
really cool feature,
I think, called Time Travel.
So the notion of Time
Travel is that because we
have these storage sets that
we're keeping for your tables,
we let you travel
back in time to see
the historical
version of a table
as it was up to seven
days in the past.
So we have these storage
sets that we're keeping.
When you go and
run a query and add
data, for example, or committing
new storage sets, what
you can do is that
when you run this query
with this clause that
says for system time as
of some timestamp,
we can go and fetch
the storage sets that were
in a committed state as
of that timestamp.
And that means that
you can read the data
as it was prior to a load job
or prior to some DML query,
for example.
So if you run a query
and you realize, oops,
I deleted all the
rows in my table,
I'd really like to get
that data back, you
can go and use this
feature called Time Travel
and use this clause to actually
read that data as it was
before you made that operation.
So where can this go wrong?
How can these storage sites
end up in a bad state?
Or are things just always happy?
So storage sets can end up
in a bad state for a couple
of different reasons.
So you can end up with
a really large number
of very small
storage sets-- end up
having, essentially, way more
metadata than you do data
if you do things like
microbatch your load job.
So if you load really
small files, like,
let's say, one every
minute, and it only
has a few rows at a
time, what ends up
happening is that we have,
essentially, more metadata
than we do data for that table.
So you can also do things
like stream at really low QPS.
So if you're streaming,
like, one row every minute,
what we end up doing is,
when we flush that data,
we're writing very small
storage sets periodically
to that table.
Or if you perform very small
DML queries-- at least for now.
So this is sort of
a snapshot in time.
So the way that
DML works currently
is that we're committing a
storage set for each of the DML
queries that you perform.
I say this is a snapshot
in time because this
is subject to change
in the future.
So what's the actual
symptom of this?
Well, for one thing,
queries can take a long time
to fetch metadata for executing.
I mentioned that we do
that read from Spanner
of all those storage sets.
So if you have, let's
say, one per minute
that you are creating
as part of these loads,
we can end up with
more than 1,000 storage
sets over the course of a day.
And so we have to
go and fetch all
of those, which includes
things like the column sizes
and so on.
That's a lot to
actually fit in memory
and pass around the system.
And so your queries
can actually end up
taking a bit longer
than you would
expect even though
it may be processing
a small amount of data.
Or because we use the
number of files and storage
sets, for example, as
a hint for parallelism.
We can end up using
more workers to try
to process your data than
we would normally do.
So what can you do instead?
Well, as you may
have guessed, you
can perform less frequent,
larger load jobs.
So we provide the ability
to specify a glob pattern.
And you can load a
bunch of data at a time
by matching a pattern that's
on cloud storage, for example.
Or you can stream
at a higher QPS.
Basically, use the
right API for the job.
So if you have a lot of data
that's flowing continuously
over time, you probably
want to use the streaming
API rather than the load API.
On the flipside,
if you have data
that's writing very
infrequently in larger batches,
use the load API.
Or, execute larger DML queries.
So if you have a
lot of rows that you
want to modify, instead
of running 10 DML queries,
for example, just run one
that modifies all of them
in one pass.
But even if you don't,
there's a silver lining here.
So BigQuery manages
your data for you.
And what I mean by this is that
even if you have these storage
sets in bad state, BigQuery
has a background process that
goes and fixes that for you.
So you don't need to worry
about this, to some extent.
So even if you don't follow
these best practices right,
we have this
optimization process
running behind the scenes that
fixes up your data for you
and gets it into a better state
so that your queries are then
faster as a result.
So let's transition a bit to
the topic of querying metadata.
So we recently released
something cool called
INFORMATION_SCHEMA views.
So if you're familiar
with the SQL standard--
I've read it probably
more than I would like--
there's this chapter
called Schemata.
So schemata describes these
INFORMATION_SCHEMA views.
They give you a structured
way of referencing metadata
in the system.
So far in BigQuery, this
means that we include
things like schemata view.
This gives you
data set, metadata.
We have table-related views.
There's a view about
views themselves.
We have columns information.
And we have a
BigQuery-specific extension
called COLUMN_FIELD_PATHS
that gives you
an overview of the nested
data that you have.
And we're going to keep
adding more over time.
So as a very quick
overview of these, so
we have these schemata views.
And this gives you
data set metadata.
So in this example,
I'm running a query
that gives me the
locations of all the data
sets in this BigQuery public
data project broken down
by region.
So I can see that I have four
data sets in the EU region,
and the rest appear to
be in the US region.
I have table metadata.
So I'm able to run this query
over the San Francisco data
set, for example, and
see these tables that
have the prefix
"bike," in this case.
I have a views metadata table.
So this gives me information
about the actual definition
of these views.
So I can go run a query and pull
the definition of all the views
that I've stored in BigQuery.
There is the columns view.
So this gives me information
about the column names
and their types,
which ones are used
for partitioning, which ones
are used for clustering--
that sort of thing.
And I can go and run a query
to figure out, essentially,
any information that I
want about these columns.
We also have this
BigQuery-specific extension
called COLUMN_FIELD_PATHS.
So this lets you actually
analyze the paths
to the data themselves.
So you can have strucs.
For example.
In BigQuery, you
can have arrays--
that kind of thing.
This basically gives you a
way of understanding the paths
to data that you can use.
So in this example, I have
this inputs column and outputs
column.
And both of these have fields
underneath them called value.
And so I'm able to figure
out that both of those
have numeric type and
I'm able to analyze
that at that
[INAUDIBLE] field level.
So I have a short
example on this.
So I'm going to tie all these
concepts together in a query,
actually.
If we could switch to the
demo, that would be great.
So in this demo,
what I'm doing is,
I'm actually rebuilding
the create table statements
that I can use for my tables.
So I have a variety
of attributes here.
So one is, I have this function
for making the partition
by expression for my tables.
I have this clause
that I'm generating.
So here's the actual
partition by text itself.
Cluster by-clause for
any cluster tables.
I build the column
[INAUDIBLE] itself.
Any options associated
with the table.
And then I take these
various components
and I combine them
all together in order
to generate this create or
replace table statement.
So what you can see here is that
I've generated these results.
Let me zoom out a bit,
actually, so you can see better.
So I've generated all
these create or replace
tables statements that recreate
the definitions of my tables
from these columns.
And I have this partition by
attribute, options list, et
cetera.
So that's pretty cool.
You can also find this example
in our public documentation.
We added this.
If you search for
information schema,
we show you how to
do this yourself.
Can we switch back to
the slide deck, please?
Something else I'd
like to talk about
is that we're announcing a new
feature around encrypting PII.
So when you manage
PII in BigQuery,
there's a couple of things
that I want to mention first.
So keep in mind that
data in BigQuery
is always encrypted at rest.
Whenever we store your
data, those capacitor files
that are on disk are kept
in an encrypted format.
Our API endpoints use HTTPS,
so clients encrypt requests,
as well.
You can also use CMEK to encrypt
specific tables with a key,
essentially that you manage
yourself if you want to.
And we provide an API called
Data Loss Prevention that
can help you to
classify and redact PII.
These are just some things
to keep in mind, basically,
as I'm talking about this.
So here's the problem
statement, though.
Tracking PII in your data
across many tables and data sets
is hard.
You don't necessarily
know which columns
have PII or any of the tables,
necessarily, that have PII.
It's kind of hard to
track them all down.
When you want to remove data
for a specific user, what
can be hard is to run
updates and deletes
across all the tables.
It's hard to figure
out, first of all,
what you need to actually
run those queries over.
And then it can also be
expensive to go and modify
all those, too.
So what I'm announcing today
is that encryption functions
in BigQuery are now
generally available.
So this is a pretty
powerful feature,
but it's also very low-level.
And I want to talk a bit about
how you can actually leverage
this in your applications.
These are functions for
creating key sets, performing
encryption, and decryption.
And the core use case for this
is crypto-deletion of PII.
You can keep any PII
in an encrypted format,
And then you can perform
what's called crypto-deletion.
And I'm going to show
you a bit how that works.
So how does
crypto-deletion help?
So what you can do is, you can
encrypt each of your own user's
data with a different key.
And then when you want to delete
their data, instead of tracking
it down across all the
tables that you may have,
what you can do is you
just throw away that key.
You just delete the key.
And now the data is
no longer recoverable.
So to set this up,
what you can do
is that-- imagine that you
have this customer's table,
for example.
And you want to generate a
key for each of your users.
So you can go and add a
new column to the table.
And then you can run
an update statement
to actually populate the key
sets for each of the customers
that you have.
So here, I'm using this
new key set function
and I'm generating a new key
set for each of my customers.
Now what I can do
is that when I want
to encrypt data
using these key sets,
I can run a query
like this where I
use this AEAD.ENCRYPT function.
And what I do is, I
generate cipher texts
based on that input data
that I have, using the key
set for each of my customers.
So now, each customer's data is
encrypted using their own key.
I can give somebody access
to this customer data table,
for example.
All this data is kept
in encrypted form.
And so even if somebody
had access to this,
without the key sets,
it's not readable.
There's nothing you could
do with that information,
because it's stored
in encrypted form.
I can also decrypt
data using key sets.
So I can use this DECRYPT_STING
function, for example,
and I can go ahead and recover
that data from that customer
data table using the
key sets that I have
stored in my customer table.
And then, as I mentioned, so
when I want to crypto-delete
data--
so when I have a number
of inactive customers,
somebody asks for me to
delete their data, et cetera,
what I can do is, I can go
ahead and delete those key sets.
So once those key
sets are gone, I
don't have a way of getting
that encrypted data back.
I have to use those
decryption functions in order
to decrypt that data.
And so once those key sets
are no longer available to me,
I can't recover
it at that point.
So what's cool about this is
that you can perform encryption
outside of BigQuery, too.
We have interoperability thanks
to the library that we use.
So we use this open-source
library called Tink.
There's a saying in the
industry that you should never
roll your own crypto.
We didn't try to make
that mistake in BigQuery.
We use an open-source library.
It's developed by security
engineers at Google,
so we have pretty high
confidence in this.
So we use this
library called Tink.
And what this lets you do
is that you can not only
use these functions
within BigQuery itself,
but you can also use them
in whatever applications
you build outside
of BigQuery, too.
So you can create key sets,
perform encryption, decryption,
et cetera either within your
own code or within BigQuery
directly.
So imagine you have
a scenario where
you can encrypt using
Dataflow, for example,
and then decrypt using BigQuery.
So any data stored
in your tables
is stored in encrypted form.
But you encrypted
it using Dataflow.
And you can do that
because Tink is
available as an
open-source library.
You can use it from Dataflow
or whatever other application
that you're building.
Alternatively, maybe
you store your key sets
on cloud storage and your
encrypted data in BigQuery.
So maybe you don't want to keep
the keys in BigQuery itself,
for example.
You want to keep them on
files on cloud storage.
What you can do in
that case is, you
can define an external table
over your cloud storage
key sets.
And then you can
run a query that
joins the data
between that key set
table and the encrypted data
that you have in BigQuery.
And that gives you a way
of performing decryption
in BigQuery without ever having
to keep the key sets themselves
stored in BigQuery metadata.
So finally, I've got a couple
of cool things to announce.
These are alpha announcements.
So, as you may be
familiar, alpha features
are not available
for anyone to use.
We have specific
programs around these.
So if you want access
to one of these,
please talk to whoever
your Google contact
is, whether it's a salesperson
or a customer engineer, et
cetera.
And they can help set you
up with access to these.
This is sort of an early preview
of some upcoming features
that we think that
you'll really like.
The first of these that
I'd like to mention
is our scripting alpha.
So scripting gives
you the ability
to send multiple queries
in one request to BigQuery.
It also lets you use variables.
And then, furthermore, you
can use conditions and loops
to actually manage the flow
of execution of the script
that you send to BigQuery.
So this is a really
powerful feature.
Historically, we've
always supported
running a single query
at a time in BigQuery.
So this lets you build
a lot more functionality
into BigQuery directly,
where you just hand us
the script of all the things
you want to accomplish and we go
and run it for you.
And again, if you want
to access to this,
please talk to whoever
your Google contact
is about enrolling.
Secondly, we're announcing
the alpha persistent UDFs.
So there was just a comment
on our public issue tracker
this morning.
It's been two and a half
years since somebody
requested this feature.
Why haven't you done this yet?
Well, here it is.
So we have this alpha now.
You can come and try
it if you want to.
It's been a long time in the
making, but it's finally here.
So if you've ever wanted
to reuse functions
across different queries,
or maybe somebody
has created a bunch of functions
and wants to share them
with you, you can now create
them and then share them
with anybody that you want to.
So this gives you a way
of reusing functions
instead of having to put them
all at the top of your queries,
now.
And so with that, that's
the end of my section.
Please welcome Subra to
the stage, from Home Depot.
[APPLAUSE]
SUBRA DHURJATI: Thanks, Elliot.
Most of the features mentioned
are really game-changing here.
Good morning, all.
I'm super excited to
be here before you.
My aim is to talk about
some of our experiences
in implementing an enterprise
data warehouse on the Google
platform.
Have an agenda here.
Talk a little bit
about The Home Depot--
cool, interesting facts.
Switch to enterprise
data warehouse,
which is my group here.
And then we touch upon
the facts and dimensions
before I'm going to speak
about the challenges.
I'm very sure everyone
has shopped at Home Depot.
We are big.
We are the number
one home improvement
retailer in the world.
We have 153
distribution centers.
And we have like
$100 billion sales.
My group, specifically-- the
enterprise data warehouse.
We started the journey to
implement our enterprise data
warehouse on the BigQuery
sometime around 2016.
Today, we have close to
16 petabytes of data.
As we speak, we are
still growing, actually.
We have 40,000 users across
the stores, corporate centers,
distribution centers.
And also, we do a lot of
mobile reporting and analytics
on the mobile devices.
I'm very sure everybody
knows your staff schema.
The intent is to show what it
means to us, as Home Depot.
With all the 5,000
tables that I mention,
if I draw this diagram, I'm
very sure it will cover the most
part of the wall behind me.
But as a simplicity here,
what I'm trying to show is,
we have sales.
We have orders and supply
chain, customer orders,
the classic retail
dimensions like the product,
the vendor, the stores, and
the customer, obviously.
Touch upon a minute to
talk about what facts are.
The facts means
metrics, or the measures
that are some [INAUDIBLE]
tools talk about.
Transactional in
nature, usually.
They could be streamed.
They could be in batch.
And other important thing
is, they can be additive.
Example-- sales can be
rolled across weeks or time.
Or, a classic thing is,
inventory is a snapshot.
You cannot roll it over time.
Next slide.
Here, master data.
Comparatively, they
are smaller in size.
They have attributes.
Example is a screw size.
A nail or a screw
in Home Depot could
be 3/8 size each or 1/14 size.
There's changing.
They change over time.
And they are hierarchical.
Example-- organization
hierarchy could
have a location
moving to the district
all the way up to the division.
Also, here, the primary
purpose of all the dimensions
here is to slice
and dice your facts
and then to drill up and down.
The roll up functions,
as we call them.
Challenges [INAUDIBLE].
I know as we are implementing
our enterprise data whereas--
any platform for
that matter, there'll
be tons of challenges, numerous.
And I could spend pretty
much the whole day
talking about these.
But because of
interest of time, I'll
narrow the scope to
just the dimensions,
and also touch upon
a few of these.
Whenever we are implementing
a warehouse, especially
in the data
integration space, we
want to find out, hey, what
has changed in the source?
And do a delta processing.
That's one.
And there's a big deal in pretty
much all the business, I guess,
where from a
business perspective,
we want to talk about as-is
was as as-was reporting.
I'll explain what that
is in the next slides.
And the other thing I want to
touch upon is the versioning.
How do we store history?
By the way, most of the
points are interlinked.
One key thing, again,
I want to mention
here is about surrogate keys.
One of the lessons learned with
the advent of data scientists
and analysts who can
write their own queries--
what we have found is, it's
better to avoid surrogate keys.
They're very 1999-ish
to the early 2000.
It confuses them, because you
have to now use surrogate keys
to do all the joins.
It's good for
operational reporting,
but not for deep analytics.
That's the lesson we learned.
Change data capture.
I'm very sure we have a lot of--
every company has
a lot of sources
from which we extract the data.
Some of the sources, especially
with respect to legacy,
doesn't have a method to
know what has changed.
There's no timestamp column
to know what has changed.
That's one scenario.
And there are other cases where
the source has a last update
timestamp which you
can use to extract
for the delta processing.
The third-- there are
sophisticated systems where,
for example, with database
replication, they can tell,
hey, these are all the
changes that you have.
And that makes life easier
in data integration space.
As-is as well as
as-was reporting.
It's a big deal,
actually, if you
look from a business
perspective,
especially in Home Depot.
As I mentioned in
the earlier slides,
the dimensions are hierarchical.
They change over time.
They could be still changing.
But they change over time.
So most of the businesses-- they
want to see all the metrics,
analyze all the metrics to
the current point in time,
the most recent hierarchy.
Example-- as you move to a
different department and they
want to see all the sales
rolled up to that department,
what it means--
I'm very sure a lot
of companies do build
aggregates for performance.
To [INAUDIBLE] single
version of the truth,
all the aggregates
need to be restated.
We call that internally,
in Home Depot, as recast.
So every day, we recast
all of our metrics
to the most recent hierarchy.
But there are business
analysts and data scientists,
especially in the legal
departments and the marketing,
who want to see all the metrics
to a particular point in time.
You have to go
back like, example,
give me my sales as of
the hierarchy in 2007,
or give me the address of
the customer as of 2010.
To do that, we have to
enable as-was reporting.
To do all of these, you
need to keep the history.
That's the point here, I guess.
Next slide.
This slide is multifold.
I want to talk--
I know I put as one
of the methodologies
for versioning to
implement our history,
but I'm also going to talk
about our Home Depot methodology
here, of how we do data
integration with the ELT
approach.
And the third point I
want to also make here
is, adaptable to use case
where the source does not
tell me what has changed.
So I'm going to go through that
use case, too, in this slide.
Going from left to right,
we have the source table.
It could be mainframe.
It doesn't have a
last update timestamp.
So our integration methodology
in the data injection
is to extract that
into a raw data set.
When I say raw, it
means so similar.
It's pretty much close
to what source is.
And then we have
to scrub the data.
So we scrub it.
We're using [INAUDIBLE]
bunch of BigQuery functions
that we can use
to scrub the data
and then land it into
a staging database.
Again, this is an ELTV
loading to BigQuery.
And then do all our
massaging of data there.
And then at that point,
now the data is pretty much
what we need, I guess.
But as I said, the source
didn't tell me what has changed.
It has all the rules.
So now, I'm going to go
to my yesterday's copy,
or the previous run's copy of
my target [INAUDIBLE] full outer
join figure out
what has changed.
If it is in the source
but not in target,
that means there are new rules.
If it is in target
but not in the source,
that means something
else got deleted.
If it is in both and the
columns have some different,
that means they're updated.
We take up all these
changes, stack them
up in a table which I'm calling
it as Change Capture Table.
And if you see, that's
in the data data set.
So we have a raw,
which is so similar.
We have a stage where it
is temporarily massaged.
And then the final is
all in the data data set.
The other thing is, now we have
to do the as-is was is as-was.
So to do the as-is, we use
BigQuery functions like
rollover right at the analytical
functions to get the most
recent row and put it in
the target, which is our--
we expose to business.
I didn't represent
the as-was case,
but you could always use
the analytical functions
like lead, lag, all
those functions,
and get to effective
begin and end dates and do
the as-was reporting.
One thing to point out here
is, from our legacy warehouse
to which we moved to BigQuery,
we do a one-time conversion.
And I have to put that
data into the target.
The same thing, now.
What I did is, I explained
using the data here.
And one thing I want to point
out is, there's an active flag.
So if a record has
got deleted, we
make the active flag as false.
Moving on.
Pros of this approach--
it's very easy to implement
and it's self-healing.
You basically stack
up all the changes.
Let's say if some
transaction comes late,
it still goes in and
self-heals because there's
nothing much we are doing.
We are stacking up and
pulling the latest.
It works for even stream data.
Though my example said that
I am doing a full extract,
this approach works beautifully
well for the streaming.
Cons.
One of the cons I
heard from business,
if they are not
that SQL-savvy, is,
you have to use some analytical
functions to get the as-was.
But to mitigate it, we could
always precreate the tables
and export them.
Then, if the tables
are huge, I know
sometimes the customer
dimension could
and similar dimensions could
be multi-million to billion
records.
There might be some
performance issues.
If you're joining to, really,
a multi-billion fact table,
that's one thing
to keep in mind.
We have the next approach.
Again, this slide
is also multifold.
Here, I've used
streaming use case.
But it could work
even for a patch.
Just for representation,
I put the streaming.
Moving from left to
right, in this case,
the source is sophisticated.
And by the way, these
are live examples
that we are running
in our warehouse.
So it is sophisticated.
They use a data
replication technology
to identify, give me all the
changes, including, they say,
these are inserts.
These are updates.
And these are deletes.
And we use a transport process
to put it onto the Pub/Sub.
From this point, we want EV
[INAUDIBLE] this data now.
So again, sticking
back to our Home Depot
methodology and [INAUDIBLE]
methodology here,
is to put it in raw.
We use the Dataflow to put it
into our raw database with all
these changes.
From that point, we do a
bunch of transformations
because we are following
the ELT approach, here.
We could do something
that pops up.
But for these, we are
especially using ELT--
reason being, our
technical staff
are really familiar
with the SQL.
Our existing, earlier
legacy warehouse
had a bunch of SQLs
to do the ELTs,
so it was seamless for
faster development.
We put it into the staging.
And then we use the BigQuery
merge DMO statements,
which I believe was
launched around a year ago.
I think so.
So once this was done,
most of our tables
now use this merge
statements with the effective
begin and end dates
already in the table.
Next slide.
The same thing I explained as
example with the data here.
Pros and cons.
Compared to the other one, the
pro is, the effective begin
and end date is
already in the table.
And you could do the as-was
and as-is type of reportings
easily using the effective
begin and end dates.
What we have found is, this
approach works well for tables
with--
I think we have a couple of
dimensions with a billion
records' worth with 80 columns,
and it still works well.
The cons-- it's
slightly complex.
If we stay in stacking,
we just stack it up
and pull the latest,
whereas here, you
have to take it off some
level of programming here.
And the second one-- when
we are doing streaming,
it adds a different level of
complexity here, the reason
being, you have to
now use effective
begin and end timestamps
rather than dates.
It adds a slight
layer of complexity.
What we learned.
So obviously, there
are a lot of challenges
with when you're doing a data
integration in a big enterprise
data warehouse space.
We are using the ELT
methodology because BigQuery
has all the rich functions.
And still, I haven't found
something that is not available
in BigQuery that we cannot
use to cleanse our data,
pretty much.
We use this approach to
do our data integration.
And it so far is working well.
And we migrated,
integrated close
to 5,000 tables in
less than a year.
Hey.
Spring is finally here.
It's time for yard
work and mulch and--
[LAUGHTER]
I would encourage you, stop by
your local Home Depot store.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE] one of my coworker
there will help you all.
Thank you.
Thank you all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]